every person we've had on from the movie
I want to talk about the uh
the science of the Lamb's bit oh yeah
yeah how was that for you that was
[ __ ] terrifying yeah it was it was
scary like
um because like you're the only one who
thought there was actually a rattlesnake
there yeah I was
um well because initially there was a
rattlesnake in the room
um but then they like they whatever the
animal Handler guy was like took it out
you know because Jeff was being so nice
to me that day and I should have known
like that it like something was about to
happen and he's he was just being really
nice and stuff and then he's like oh um
he's like yeah we need to change your
shirt like I was wearing like a black
shirt or something we need more more
color like in the scene so I go change
my shirt and then I come in you know
they shut the door on poopies and I and
you know it would just goes pitch black
it was [ __ ] terrifying how long were
you in there for I don't know like it
felt like for it felt like an eternity
um but it was just I guess it was
probably like a few minutes
um but they're like [ __ ] with us like
tasing us and stuff and then I like
before this all too like they're telling
us what would happen like if you got bit
by a rattlesnake you know and my anxiety
is like going through the roof just
because I'm like medical stuff it's like
the one thing that'll like make me have
a [ __ ] panic attack and heights yeah
and heights yeah Heights too
um so they're like telling us all about
how your heart will start racing and all
this [ __ ] and like how you end up like
having a heart attack and dying like if
you don't get the anti-venom soon enough
and they I guess it was like Knoxville
or someone comes up to me and puts like
something out it felt like something bit
me I I have no clue what the [ __ ] it was
and then and I'm thinking it's a snake
because they had like a Morocco they had
like Maracas or some [ __ ] like
pretending to be the snake and I started
freaking the [ __ ] out
um and then like I I have no clue how to
get the [ __ ] out of this room and then
Knox like that's the only way out like
well they sort of like pretends to break
character like we need to get him out or
whatever he got bit and then I'm
freaking the [ __ ] out because I'm like
dude I got bent what the [ __ ] is like
what is gonna happen I'm gonna die like
I'm not healthy like I'm not healthy
like it's not gonna like this is how I'm
gonna die or something and then Knox is
like it's the only way to get out and
like pushes me through the door because
I was like afraid to go in there and
there's just Marbles and like pots and
pans and [ __ ] everywhere I slit my shoes
the one who climbed over the counter
yeah yeah there's like a thing like
guard the camera people and there's like
all this stuff on it to make sure you
wouldn't go there like thumbtacks and
mouse traps and [ __ ] and I saw that like
because that stuff was on there that was
the way to go and I just climbed over
and [ __ ] yeah I just caught myself up
so if there was hell that would be it
probably yeah that felt like one of the
levels of hell
it's crazy dude and you were in there
with poopies yeah I was in their poopies
how uh often are you in contact with
poopies these days
um not a lot we were talking about maybe
making some YouTube stuff like a few
weeks ago but I haven't talked to him
since
yeah
um definitely would like to do that that
would be fun yeah I think uh I would I
would be careful about
um having like a sober
crew with you yeah yeah if you're gonna
yeah yeah I think every no matter what
you're doing it's either protecting your
sobriety or it's endangering your
sobriety yeah and hanging out with
poopies I think might
yeah right
do you like shopping on Amazon I do and
good news is Stevo's butt wipes for your
butthole are available
and if you want a real bundle of a deal
you can get Stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole plus Stephen's butthole
destroyer and Stevo's butt wipes for
your butthole it's the butthole bundle
available on Amazon right now
yeah dude